all right then timer says it's time to
start so we're going to do that so hello
everybody thank you for coming to this
session it's really nice really good to
see all these happy smiling faces so my
name is Steve and I work at Microsoft
I'm on the asp net team and i'm very
very excited to come and tell you about
this thing blazer but before we saw it
let's to do a quick hands thing how many
of you I've heard of this and feel like
you've got some idea of what the idea of
this thing is oh that's good that's like
two-thirds of you all right okay cool so
just for those of you are not sure about
what this thing is
well blazer is a new single page
application framework that we on the asp
net team are creating now at the moment
it's an experimental project and we
don't know when it's going to ship but
it is our intention to ship this we are
making it available now as something
that you can try out and give us
feedback on as we build this up towards
something that we can call a proper
product okay but with this talk let's
just set our expectations so in this
talk my goal is not to give you a sort
of step-by-step tutorial to like how to
do lists and grids and things like that
in blazer because honestly you can just
find that information on the web that's
that's boring what I want to show you is
a little bit more about why we're doing
this stuff like what is actually
changing in the technology landscape
that gives rise to this new thing Why
should there be a new thing why do you
care and how does it actually work on
the inside that's what this talk is
really going to be like so to get to
that stage we need to start by
understanding a little bit about what
the current status quo of web
application development is so this is
probably quite familiar to most of you
I'm guessing most of you work on web
applications of one kind or another so
your conventional situation is that
you've got some code that runs on the
server now it might be dotnet it might
be Java node go something else like that
it's going to run on some service
somewhere maybe they're in a cloud maybe
there's some dusty box under your
desktop or whatever it's on the server
and then you want to make some UI appear
in people's web browsers and to do that
you're going to use one of
things a single-page application
framework something like angular will
react of you something like that now
whichever one of these things you use
ultimately it's running on the
JavaScript runtime okay now maybe you
write your code in typescript or
something else but it's going to compile
to JavaScript so basically you're
writing JavaScript code and then you
deal with making these two sides of the
wire talk to each other and that's okay
this is fine but it's a little bit sad
that over on the Left they're in server
world you've got a lot of flexibility
and choices you can use whatever
language you want you can use whatever
technology stack you want but when it
comes to the browser side of the world
you're limited to things that basically
look and feel like JavaScript that's a
bit sad wouldn't it be nicer if we could
write code in any language and run it
inside the browser well that's why this
new standard web assembly has emerged
it's not really that new anymore it's
about two years that it's been out and
available now it's supported in all
current browsers all desktop browsers or
mobile browsers they're all supporting
this and in case you're not familiar
with what it is well I'm going to show
you in some detail later but for now
let's just say it's a bytecode format
it's something that you can compile to
like Java bytecode o-net bytecode you
can compile to this from any language
that supports compiling to web assembly
and then you can run it inside your
browser and this allows us to bring
other languages into the browser okay so
if we've got that if we've got web
assembly then maybe that means we could
run dotnet on top of it and if we had
dotnet running inside a browser well
that leads us on to blazer blazer is our
UI platform running on dotnet inside a
browser on webassembly to allow you to
build rich web UIs in a hopefully more
productive and pleasant way than you've
done before so why would anyone care why
would you want to write your web UI in
dotnet well there's potentially quite a
lot of benefits and I'm gonna go through
some of them but you don't really just
want to hear me talk you want me to to
actually show you some of these benefits
in practice so let's do some demos okay
let me create a bit of a blazer
application and I'll talk you through
some of these advantages that we can
potentially get starting with the
use of the c-sharp language okay so I'm
switching over into visual studio here
where I've created a project already and
I'll show you some of the code in it in
a minute but let's just start it running
inside my browser here and you can see
that this is a pretty normal dashboard
kind of application it's got a few
different pages in it I can go backwards
and forwards
that's client side navigation we're not
making new HTTP requests to the server
when I do that we've got some static
content we've got an example of this
counter thing that just counts how many
times you click on a button which is you
know kind of dull but you know it shows
you something and then we've got this
fetch data page which is an example of
making an HTTP request to the server to
get some data and then rendering that as
an HTML table so classic single page
application the sort of thing that you
would normally build with react or view
or angular something like that that
would run on the JavaScript runtime but
in this application there is no
JavaScript at all so to prove that let's
have a look at some of the code that's
in there so and we will zoom in a little
bit so we can see it and you'll see what
we've got in here is we've got some CSS
some HTML we've got some CS HTML files
which are RAZR files you might or might
not know that depending on whether
you've worked with ASP net before I'll
show you that in a sec and at the bottom
here we've got these c-sharp files so
this is a pure dotnet application which
we're compiling and running on top of
web assembly inside the browser okay but
what does this really look like what are
all these CS HTML files well each one of
these CS HTML files is a component so
Blazer follows on from a very similar
architecture that you'll see in most
modern spa frameworks today where the
entire UI is constructed out of
components and a component is basically
any piece of UI it can be the entire
application UI it can be a layout it can
be an individual page it could be just a
small group of HTML elements whatever
you want
it's just components all the way down
you can nest these things and build a
complex UI out of them so show you
examples then so let's start with the
simplest one here
got a bit of static content so what does
it take to have some static content well
it's completely trivial so let's zoom in
a bit so as you can see the simplest
component is just some static HTML
markup we've also got this page
directive at the top that says this is
the coma component that we're going to
use if the user is on our home page okay
so that's just static markup we can also
put some dynamic stuff in here like this
counter and the code for that looks like
this okay what we've got is again we're
using this page directive to respond to
this particular URL and then down here
we've got a functions block and because
this is a dotnet application we can put
some arbitrary c-sharp code into here
and so that's what we're doing we've got
this current count field which starts at
zero and then in our markup we're using
razor syntax which is a way of using
c-sharp from inside HTML to display the
value of current count right there then
we've also got an HTML button and we're
saying when this button is clicked we're
going to call this c-sharp method
increment count and the increment count
method just does what you think it would
do it increases the value of current
count and the UI updates and everyone is
happy and we get very rich ok so that's
a very simple component that displays
some dynamic data what about this one
this is a little bit more involved it
makes an HTTP request to the server
let's have a look at the code in there
so again we're using this page
declaration at the top there we're also
using inject and inject ties into asp
net dependency injection system and that
gives us an instance of HTTP client so
we can make some requests and if we look
down here right at the bottom you'll see
when this thing starts up we're
asynchronously going to do an HTTP GET
request for some JSON data and we're
going to get that from this plain JSON
file just to show you that we can and
when that data comes back we're going to
deserialize it as an array of weather
forecast objects and we've defined the
weather forecast type here as a nested
class and that defines the type of stuff
on it and then up here we can use razor
syntax to say we'll iterate or
each of these forecasts and for each one
will display a little bit of HTML stuff
okay so I hope that seems reasonably
straightforward so far a component is a
file that you can put some c-sharp and
some marker pen and then you can make it
do whatever you want you can do loads of
stuff with components you can nest them
together you can pass parameters into
them you can have events on them you can
do all kinds of cool stuff and I'll show
you a little bit of that as we go
through okay so we can use some c-sharp
to build our application what else could
we do that's useful well we can take
advantage of the full dotnet ecosystem
and that gives us access to a very wide
range of built in a ready-made
functionality so an example of that
let's say you've just built this
application you and you show it to your
manager or some business analyst in your
company what's the business analysts
gonna say well the first thing is
they'll say oh that's really cool well
done now I need to be able to export
that data to excel so I can do some
business analytics on it and you'll say
oh ok fine right I'll then I'll make you
a CSV file and they'll say no I don't
want to CSV file I want a proper
spreadsheet I don't want plain text I
want colors I want formatting I want
graphs so on formulas I want all that
stuff and you think oh grace oh right
how am I going to make this Excel
spreadsheet for you and the answer to
that is very easily because it's the
sort of problem that dotnet developers
solve every day you know before the
morning coffee because it's very very
basic what we're going to do is we're
going to go and get a ready-made dotnet
package from the new get package manager
that helps us to make Excel spreadsheets
so I'm going to go to manage NuGet
packages and I know the fonts a bit
small here so I'll zoom in a bit now
I've already downloaded this one just in
case the network connection was a bit
dodgy this is EP plus it's like the
number seventh most popular new get
package of all time or something it's
millions of downloads because we all
need to make spreadsheets right so I'm
going to add this to my project here and
we'll get rid of all this stuff that it
displays and now I can start making a
spreadsheet so what am I going to do
first I want to add a button that when
you click it is going to trigger the
download so down here inside my markup
I'm going to use an HTML button
zoom out bit all right we'll have an
HTML button and we'll say when you click
it we're going to call this method
download file and Visual Studio says
hang on there is no download file method
and that is going to be a problem for me
so you think all right fine I will
create you a download file method and
the empty download file method is going
to look a bit like this
okay so doesn't do anything it just logs
something to the console all right so
now how do we actually create this
spreadsheet well we go and read the docs
for EP Plus and it tells us that in
order to get started you need to
construct a new excel package and then
we can add a forecasts worksheet to this
spreadsheet and then finally we'll say
ok we want the browser to download this
as a file and the contents of it will be
the bytes from our Excel spreadsheet ok
so let's compile that and then I'll go
back and I'll run that in my browser and
hopefully will actually download a
spreadsheet when we click a button so
when that comes up we've got our
download button I click on it and what
does it do it says aha ok we are trying
to open forecasts dot xlsx and I click
on that and you know it's gonna do the
thing it's gonna open it in Excel but
it's gonna be empty right well it's not
quite empty we've got this forecasts
worksheet down here you can just allow C
but I didn't put any actual data in it
so let's put some n Shoei so I'm just
going to start dumping in some big
blocks of pre-prepared code now firstly
I want to insert the actual data with
the weather forecast
so I'm gonna say starting from this
particular cell I'm going to use a
c-sharp linked expression to pick out
what data I want and you know I've got
access to the full c-sharp language so I
can use things like where clauses and
things like that if I want to but I
don't I just want to get all the
forecasts data and I want to put it all
into my spreadsheet ok now just to show
that this is a real spreadsheet let's do
some fancy things let's do some
conditional formatting so we want the
colors of the cells to vary between sky
blue and red depending on the
temperature that we're displaying in
that row ok what else do we want to do
well I'm going to put in a formula so
I'm going to compute the temperature
in Fahrenheit based on the temperature
in Celsius using this excel formula okay
and what else well I'm going to dump in
a big pile of markup a big pile of text
that you won't have time to read and
it's just going to say let's set loads
of things like horizontal alignment and
background colors and bold fonts and
other things like that just to show that
we can do all that sort of thing so now
when I reload and I come back and I
download this time hopefully when I open
my spreadsheet it won't be empty it will
actually contain the data that we've had
in the UI just there and that is a real
spreadsheet it's not just static so if I
change this 33 to let's say minus 5 then
you'll see the cell becomes blue because
of the conditional formatting and the
temperature F updates and so on so it's
a real real spreadsheet ok very good
all right so what was the point of
showing that it's just to show you that
we can take whatever we want from the
dotnet ecosystem and we can bring it
into the browser run it as part of our
blazer application under web assembly
now finally what's this about full stack
development ok well the application that
we've got here the code in this
application this is a true client-side
application it does not depend on there
being any nap on the server at all when
we publish this it's just static files
as far as the web server is concerned
you can serve this from a node app or
PHP or you can serve it from github
pages or as your blob storage or
anything you want it doesn't matter
what's on your server it's just static
files and I'll show you what those files
actually are later ok so standalone
blazer app does not depend on you having
dotnet on the server but what if you do
have done out on the server are there
potentially some benefits to having
dotnet on both sides of the wire well
yes there are let me show you so I'm
going to create an entirely new blazer
project right now so I'm going to create
a new asp net core web application and
I'll give it the exciting name web
application 181 there you see I create
quite a few of these things and we can
pick which of the many templates we want
to use now we've got three built-in
blazer templates we
got the standalone client-side one that
I just used for the previous demo we've
got this next one which host set on a
dotnet web application back-end which
I'm going to show you now and then
finally we've got this mysterious
server-side one we'll get to later on
okay so what does it mean to create a
blazer asp net core hosted application
well when you create a project with this
template you don't just get one project
you get three okay what are these three
let's have a look we get a client a
server and a shared project the client
is the same thing we just saw before
it's a set of Blaser components and it
runs under web assembly inside the
browser the server is a regular asp net
core server and we can pour API
endpoints on that or whatever else we
want to control what's actually going on
on the server but the most interesting
bit is the shared class library and this
is very simple it's just a plain c-sharp
class library but the cool thing about
it is that it is consumed by both the
server and client projects so any code
that you want to share between server
and client you can put there in the
shared project so let me just run this
and you will see that it does the same
thing that we saw with the other
application okay so it looks the same
got the same functionality in it but one
thing that's a little different this
time is this weather forecast data it's
not coming coming from a static file
anymore it's now coming from a real API
endpoint on the server and specifically
it's this one it's this weather
forecasts action which is returning you
know random weather forecasts but the
the important thing is we're returning
an enumerable of weather forecast
objects from the server here and then on
the client you'll see down at the bottom
we're fetching the weather forecast
subjects so the server sends our weather
forecast the client receives a weather
forecast we don't have to define the
weather forecast type inside our client
project because that is coming from the
shared project so server and client are
trivially sharing code not just
necessarily for fixed fields like this
we can put actual
in here or validation rules anything we
want to share between server and client
can go there so that potentially gives
us a very productive way of building a
full stack web application now there's
other benefits of running our net core
as well you know dotnet core is
incredibly fast by modern standards the
tooling that we have for dotnet core and
Visual Studio and V s code is you know
absolutely industry-leading everybody is
well aware that the intellisense is
really good and you know it's very nice
to work with as a developer and also
it's a stable ecosystem dotnet is
expected to be used for projects that
live on the order of 5 or 10 years or 15
years we don't completely change tough
like every three months so you know
you've got some decent guarantees that
you're gonna be able to build your
project over long term here ok so that's
some of the benefits of doing this but I
now want to switch gears a bit and think
about how does this stuff actually work
what is going on behind the scenes here
well the way this works is a combination
of three technologies working together
so I'm going to show you each of them in
turn to build up this sort of layer cake
here of technologies and the bottom of
the stack here the place where it starts
is with web assembly and I just told you
a minute ago that web assembly is a form
of bytecode that you can run in your
browser but have you actually seen
webassembly bytecode you know what it
looks like do you know how to create the
bytecode yourself
let me show you I'll give you a little
demo so let's see can I just change this
font size a bit let's have no I can't
nevermind alright so I've got some files
here I've got this file Fibonacci dot C
and that is a very simple implementation
of building the Fibonacci series in C
now the Fibonacci series is just a
series of numbers let's define
mathematically it goes 1 1 2 3 5 8
something like that I don't know and
there's a simple rule that defines each
term in the series and I've written that
in C okay so if I show you the source
code for Fibonacci I see hopefully I'll
not be too scary even if you've not seen
C before it's got a main function
it's saying we want to call print for
Bonacci to get the first 10 terms from
the series and print Fibonacci takes
that number of terms and then it loops
until we've printed all the terms we
want we print the current one we compute
the next we print the next we compute
the next and so on so that's written in
C and I could compile that to make a
native application if I wanted but I
don't want what I want is to compile to
make a web assembly application so I'm
going to do so using the M script earn C
compiler which is the compiler that
everyone uses to create web assembly by
code and I want it to compile Fibonacci
C to produce a version of Fibonacci that
can run under JavaScript okay so when
that has done its job if I view that
you'll see we've just created these two
new files Fibonacci dot wasum here on
the right that's the actual bytecode for
this application but for this you know
trivial few lines of code and I'll show
you what's in there in a minute
also Fibonacci J s is something that you
can load into your browser in a normal
way to execute it so it's a wrapper
around the web assembly file so if I
want to actually run this I need to load
it in a web page so I've got this index
to HTML let me just show you what's in
there not very much probably not even
technically valid but it's good enough
all it is is just a script tag that
loads Fibonacci j/s okay so let's start
running that in a browser okay let's go
to localhost port 8080 and we'll open
the console and you'll see that we do
indeed run the the thing and it
generates the first 10 terms of the
Fibonacci series okay but what what is
this code that's actually running what
does it look like I'll switch over the
debugger tab and let's have a look and
see what we've got well if only I had a
big enough screen to do that all right
there we go
our end so what we've got here oh
actually I want to compile this again
with with debugging enabled I want
source maps here so I'm pressing this
extra parameter okay so now I've done
that I'm gonna be able to show you this
in a more useful way because we've got
source maps you can see we now see the
actual C source code here
in the browsers debug tools and I can
even set a breakpoint on it so how cool
is this
we've just compiled some C code to
something that can run in a browser we
can see the C code and we can step
through it in a debugger in the browser
okay so that's pretty awesome but we're
not really running C here what we're
really running is webassembly bytecode
what even is that what does it look like
let's have a look at the actual
underlying buy code that's being shown
in the form of C so if I switch over
here
this is webassembly bytecode okay so
normally on disk it's in a binary format
that you can't possibly read but Firefox
shows it to us in a human readable well
I don't know if it depends if you're the
right kind of human then maybe you can
read this sort of thing but it's
difficult to make sense so I appreciate
but we can understand some of it I hope
so anyway if I scroll down a bit you
might see some bits that make sense okay
we've got a function called print
Fibonacci all right and what does that
do well it does things like it declares
a couple of Const s' 0 and 1 and that
happens to correspond to these two
constants here in our C source code and
then what does it do well it does a loop
just like the loop in our C code and it
does lots of numerical additions and
things and then eventually it calls
printf and that's going to actually
print stuff out so if we wanted to we
can set our very point here inside
webassembly and start stepping through
it like that so this is what webassembly
bytecode looks like it's a stack based
virtual machine that operates on a bunch
of different numeric types and it's very
very fast code compiled to webassembly
typically will run at within a factor of
two of the equivalent native code so if
I just compiled this to native x64
machine code and ran it it would only be
about twice as fast as running it under
web assembly in Firefox at least other
browsers very slightly okay so that is
the bottom of our cake there webassembly
and once we've got that we can build on
top of it something like dotnet so how
could we run dotnet on top of web
assembly well one way that's quite
obvious is we could somehow translate
the dotnet code into web assembly code
and if we could do that it would run
so that's the first way we could do it
the other way we could do it the way
that we actually have done it is we
could compile the dotnet runtime itself
to webassembly
and then we could just run normal dotnet
assemblies on top of that so that's what
we've done we've taken the mono runtime
and compiled it to web assembly so it
can run inside a browser now why did we
do mono well mono is one of the three
net runtimes that Microsoft makes and
why are there three different ones
well historical reasons but the point is
as a developer you don't really need to
care about the differences they all come
grunt net code you just run use
whichever one is available on your
platform and mono is the one that we can
compile to web assembly because it's the
most portable of them all so how does ma
know over and on top of web assembly let
me show you so here's our application
from before remember
now let's think about what we're
actually sending to the web browser here
this is the initial HTML that's going to
the browser you can see it doesn't have
a lot in it the only interesting thing
it's got in it is this script tag which
is going to load blazer webassembly J's
and that is a standard JavaScript file
that ships inside blazer and that is
what knows how to load up the mono
runtime under web assembly and load your
dotnet application into it okay let's
actually see that happening then let's
see what we're sending over the wire if
I go over onto the network tab here and
I hit reload then we'll see what we're
actually transferring to the browser is
the following
firstly we're sending that HTML file
which I just showed you and that tells
the browser to load this CSS and this
JavaScript file and other things and
after it's done that the Blazer drap
webassembly dot JS file is going to load
mono j is a mono wasum and that is what
we get when we compile mono to web
assembly the webassembly bytecode and a
javascript wrapper around it and so that
can then start running inside the
browser and when we've got that we can
load some dotnet assemblies into it
so that's what we're doing here we're
loading the excitingly named web
application 181 client DLL and that has
got all these other dependencies system
core system DLL blah blah blah blah blah
we load all these into the
and they can just run these are normal
dotnet assemblies nothing special web
assembly about them is just regular
assemblies that we can learn and run
under mana so you might be thinking okay
but you're loading an entire dotnet
runtime into a webpage there's gonna be
like 100 megabytes or something this is
insane so how big is this webpage anyway
well it is this big it's 1.9 5 megabytes
which is pretty small for an entire net
runtime and the libraries we need to run
our application on the other hand is
kind of big for a webpage right 2
megabytes so yeah we're aware of that
and our goal is to make this as small as
we can obviously we think we can make it
quite a lot smaller than that but this
is as far as we've got with the
optimization so far in a lot of cases
it's not going to make any difference to
you for something like an intranet
application but obviously for a public
facing Internet application is something
you want to bear in mind okay so that's
mono finally the top and most delicious
layer of our cake is blazer itself and
that is the UI stack that's designed to
run on web assembly okay and I've
already shown you a bit of blazer code
for example I showed you this counter
yeah but again how does it actually
execute we can get the idea that this is
dotnet code so it can run under mono
under web assembly but what is all this
stuff like how does this execute this is
this is text you can't execute text can
you so what are we doing here well the
answer to that is that the Blazer
compiler converts this stuff into a
dotnet class that can execute and if you
want to see the class itself I can show
you it goes into this hidden top-secret
location that no one knows about and
this is what actually gets generated
it's a class which in this case is
called counter because that's what our
file is called and if we scroll down a
bit you'll recognize some parts of it so
that's the code that we just wrote and
that just gets dumped straight into the
middle of little middle of your class
and then as for this markup up here what
we do is we translate that into a bunch
of rendering instructions so it's not
just a big old string here it's a set of
instructions to do things like open
element add some content into it open an
element called button put an attribute
on N and so on so what's happening at
runtime here is every time we want to
render your component we render it to an
in-memory data structure that represents
the the UI tree we call it a render tree
this is a similar technique that many
other spar frameworks use instead of
operating on the Dom directly they
operate on a data structure in memory
and then every time your component
renders weak and if the data structure
against the previous version for that
one and we can figure out exactly what's
changed in the UI and we can apply the
minimal updates to the diff to the Dom
so if I go over here and when I click
this button the only part of the UI
that's getting updated when I click this
is that text node there with the three
on it so it's very very efficient in
terms of how we actually update the UI
okay so that is our completed wonderful
technology cake there going all the way
from web assembly up to Blaser running
on top of that but I've only shown you
one side of the story so far there's
actually more to blazer that you can do
than just build applications like that
so let me tell you about other ways that
you can run this so why I've shown you
so far is how we can have a browser and
we can have blazing running inside of it
on top of mono on top of web assembly
and then we can do all the UI executions
we can build the diffs and we can apply
the Dom all entirely inside the browser
and that's a true client-side
application but this architecture is
very flexible because we've got this
separation between how the UI updates
are computed and how they actually get
applied we can restructure the
application in some interesting ways for
example what if we were to take Blazer
out of the browser and run it on your
server in the cloud instead and then
when it comes to actually displaying the
UI in the browser
we could compute those diffs on the
server and send them to the browser over
say a WebSocket connection it could
apply the UI there and when they're
events it can send
back up into the server and the cycle
continues so this is a method that we've
called server-side Blazer or to give it
its new name razor components so this
approach turns out to be extremely
compelling in a lot of situation I'll
talk about some of the pros and cons in
a minute but a lot of people are very
very into this approach and do you
remember before I said that the
client-side version of blazer is it's
experimental we don't know exactly when
it's going to ship even though we do
plan to ship it well the server-side
version of blazer that's not
experimental we know exactly when that's
going to ship that is committed to be
part of asp net core 3.0 so that's
something that you are definitely going
to be able to use in production pretty
soon okay so I'll talk about the pros
and cons of this in a minute but let me
just show you it actually working to
illustrate what I've just said so I'm
going to switch over yet again to
another project and this has been built
with the blazer server-side template so
when I run this now you'll see that once
again it looks more or less the same and
behave the same I've got this extra page
at the bottom which we'll get to in a
minute which I've added for this demo
but you know it does the same things but
let's actually I want to show you this
city in chrome because it's got a better
debug tools for WebSockets so first
thing to notice is look how quick this
loads when I click reload it's just boom
it's just there and in terms of what
we're sending over the wire it's far far
more minimal when I reload with hard
reload so it's not using the cache
you'll see that it's not 2 megabytes
anymore it's 100 kilobytes so it's far
far more lightweight in fact we could
make this much smaller we could probably
get this down to about 30 kilobytes
particularly if we took all the
bootstrap and stuff out of it so it's
very lightweight and we're not fetching
the dotnet runtime into the browser
anymore what we're doing instead is
we're opening a WebSocket connection
back to the server and that's what this
underscore blazer request is here that's
for a WebSocket
URL that's the ws there in the URL and
if I click on that we can see what's
going over the wire or we can a little
bit you'll note that whenever I click
this button you'll see a little bit of
traffic goes across the wire so we're
sending a message to the server to say
hey
this event that's a 371 byte message and
the server says okay here's the updates
to the UI in response and that's 61
bytes coming back and then we've got
some bits of housekeeping that come with
it as well but the point here is it's
extremely lightweight the total amount
of traffic in response to an event like
this is measured in the tens or hundreds
of biiss it's incredibly minimal in
terms of wire traffic okay so that is
showing you it working but let's talk
about the pros and cons of this compared
with client side blazer for a minute so
on the pro side the most obvious one is
that it takes all the load away from the
client the client becomes an extremely
thin client all it has to do is apply
these UI diffs that the server gives it
so you're sending it very very little
code you just give and get the actual UI
it's incredibly fast you know it works
with the most ancient browsers it's very
very compatible with whatever kind of
client you want because we're running
the code on the server now we're running
on the full net core runtime which means
that there's absolutely no scenarios
where you're limited in terms of what
code you can write you've got access to
your full server runtime all the
resources available on your server and
everything is going to be stupendously
fast and then finally in terms of
simpler architecture well I'll explain
that in a minute but let's just talk
about the cons as well because there are
some because we're depending on the
server now for every single UI update
this application cannot work offline the
client-side one can work offline it can
be a PWA or something else like that but
the server one cannot it's using the
server for every UI update the other
main drawback is latency now this is the
sad thing about physics the physics
physicists have not yet figured out any
way to make light any faster and light
is disappointingly very very slow so if
your server is 200 milliseconds away in
terms of speed of light well it's going
to take 200 milliseconds for every UI
update thats just like basic physics we
can't do anything about that
unfortunately so for an intranet
application or a geographically
distributed application it's not an
issue but if you are you know for a
public application if your servers in
Australia and you
here gonna be a bit of latency so you
have to bear that in mind and finally
you're using your server resources for
every single UI update so you're paying
the cost of that CPU time which is
different from other client where the
client brings their own CPU time and you
don't have to pay for it okay so what do
I mean by simpler architecture what I
mean by that is you potentially can
remove one of the layers from your from
your architecture diagram normally when
you've got some code running on the
client if it wants to run some code on
the server you have to go through some
HTTP endpoint so you want to do a
database request you're gonna make an
HTTP call and then it does the database
request but with server-side Blaser your
code is already on the server so you
don't have to go through an extra hop to
get to the server so to give you an
example of the benefit of that let's
consider some kind of funky machine
learning scenario okay so I've got this
reviews page over here where I want
people to write some reviews of another
stuff in general okay and our business
analysts tell us that it's good for
business when people write happy reviews
and it's bad if people write sad reviews
so we need to know if someone seems too
sad and if they are we're gonna block
them from submitting the review okay
that seems reasonable so to do that
we're going to want to do some fancy
machine learning thing to figure out
whether the user is happy or sad but we
want to run that on the server because
our machine learning model is very
computationally expensive and even if it
wasn't it's highly proprietary and we
don't want to disclose how it works to
the client so here's how the code for
this is going to work we've got this
reviews component here which says you
know tell us what you think it's got a
button which to be honest doesn't do
anything and then we've got a text area
below that and we've got an on input
event so every time there's a keystroke
we're going to call this update score
method and it's going to figure out what
text the user is just entered and then
it's going to call our machine learning
model this is a real ml net model I'm
not going to go through the code but
it's kind of simple so it takes some
text input it produces a probability of
happiness where 0 is like desperately
sad and 1 is the the highest level of
ecstasy that a human being can possibly
experience
okay then we're multiplying that by a
hundred to get a probability and this is
this what we're doing so I'm I'm loading
a pre-prepared machine learning model
called sentiment dot zip and I can
predict someone's happiness based on
that so I am then predicting their
happiness and then I'm passing that
updated happiness to the happiness scale
at the point of me showing you this is
just that I don't have to go through an
HTTP request to do that if I want to
call some server-side code I just call
it because my code is already on the
server so if I'm over here and I write
this is terrible
it sucks I never want to see this again
you can see that the user is extremely
unhappy but if we change it to this is
great it is nice I want to see this
again then you know we know that our
user is much happier and we can accept
their review all right so that's
server-side Blaser
okay finally the third way that we can
run a blazer application what if we want
to build a native desktop app didn't
think about that hmm so what if we want
to build a Windows application or a Mac
or Linux desktop application could we
use blazer for that yes we could so we
could take the same blazer components
that work client-side on web assembly
and they also work server-side and we
could run them on type of dotnet core
which is cross-platform okay if you
didn't get the message yet it's been
cross-platform for several years now so
we can run blazer on dotnet
cross-platform and use that to update
the UI inside an electron application
let me give you a very quick example of
that so we did an experiment to see if
we could port the azure storage Explorer
desktop application to blazer and so
that's what this is so it looks like a
regular dotnet application it is a dot
there application it's all nice and fast
it's very scalable you know we've got
this grid with 100,000 items in it we
can do all the things like fetching some
stuff from a network so let's see what
we've got inside the asp net core test
account
we've got some screenshots that
someone's added of something I can
download that I can launch that in the
operating system image viewer so I've
got screenshots something from Windows
great and this is a set of Blazer
components everything you see here is a
big nested hierarchy of Blazer
components which is running under
electron to produce a very responsive
cross cross platform desktop application
so that's yet another way that you can
use your laser components so there we go
that is hopefully pretty much the whole
story of what we can do with blazer at
the moment it's a actual single page
application framework that's built with
dotnet it's got all the kind of features
that you would need to build a realistic
large application there we can run it on
the client we can run it on the server
we can run it under electron and you
should try it out so to try it out go to
blazing app download app follow the
tutorials and become a more happy and
fulfilled person so I hope that's fun
for you enjoy the rest of your tour your
conference and remember to press the
buttons on your way out thank you
[Applause]